it's great to trace things back to Alan
Turing you know he's in Bletchley Park
England he had come up with the concept
of the universal computing machine but
then he has to help put it in practice
to break the German wartime code so he
comes up with a device called ah the
bomb and then Colossus and these are
machines that can break the code and he
starts thinking about the difference
between human imagination and machine
intelligence and he goes back to what he
calls lady Lovelace's objection goes
back to Ada Lovelace a hundred years
earlier who had said machines will be
able to do everything except think and
so Turing comes up with what he calls
the imitation game now we call it the
Turing test in which it tries to figure
out how would you tell the difference
between a human and a machine how would
you know the machines not intelligence
says we'll put a human in the machine in
a different room we send them in
questions and if after a while you can't
tell which ones a machine and which ones
a human then it makes no sense to say
the machine isn't thinking now you can
have philosophical arguments about
whether or not that's a good test but
ever since then it's been about 65 years
since he came up with that concept we've
been trying to invent machines that
would pass the Turing test or the
imitation game every now and then you
read about a machine that can sort of do
conversational gambits and maybe confuse
a person for five minutes or so and sort
of try to pass the Turing test but
surprisingly we found it very difficult
to have machines that can really carry
on a conversation and be confused with a
human you can usually tell the machine
from the human a different way of
looking at the way the computer age
evolved is sort of ADA Lovelace's way
which is that computers and humans will
evolve symbiotically they'll be partners
we will get more intimately connected to
our machines and the machines will
amplify our intelligence and our
creativity will amplify what the
machines could do and we don't need to
try to create robots that'll work
without us it's kind of cooler to create
this partnership of humans and
technology or
she put it the humanities and
engineering so those are really the two
schools of thought in computer
programming and every now and then you
hear people say the singularities coming
we're about to get to the age of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and I suspect it may come but
it's always about 20 years away and in
the meantime it's sort of the Ada
Lovelace vision rather than the Alan
Turing vision the vision of having
machines that connect to us more
intimately rather than replace us and
don't need us anymore